good morning John Here I am once again
trying to film my video as the Sun is
setting so the video quality is going to
be decreasing as the Sun Goes Down
hopefully I can do this video in a
linear fashion because I'm gonna make a
video there's like stuff in the end that
stops at the beginning and the beginning
this chapter at the end but if the light
is changing rapidly as it is right now
it becomes very obvious that I'm doing
that so I told you 50 things that I was
thankful for yesterday and I'm gonna
tell you it is now the day before
Thanksgiving which I have to tell you is
actually the opposite of Thanksgiving
it's called Thanksgiving and it is the
day on which I tell you all the things
that annoy the crap out of me the things
I am not thankful for I am annoyed by
the way that my finger tips constantly
hurt after playing guitar for two weeks
straight ow
they're hard like Little Rock's I'm
annoyed by people who leave YouTube
comments telling me that I have an
unsupportable position on the national
anthem okay maybe I didn't say this
quite as eloquently as I should have in
the last that yeah my real problem with
the national anthem now that I have some
time to talk about it is that it is this
song about the defense of ideals not a
song about the ideals themselves I know
that we have to defend the ideals and I
do not want to belittle the bravery and
sacrifice made by Americans over the
last 200 years to protect those ideals
I'm just saying what I love about
America isn't the fact that we can
defend our ideals every country defends
their ideals that's the point of a
country but I like that we have good
ideals moving on I am annoyed that every
single character on television these
days seems to be named Hank playoff it
television writers it's enough of the
Hanks no more Hanks I was fine
when Hank Hill came on the air I was
even okay with mr. Hankey the Christmas
poo
even though that happened to me in
middle school which is not a good time
to have a poop named after you but I'm
not okay with this there are three main
characters on television right now named
Hank there's Hank Moody of
Californication there's a whole show
named Hank and there's this guy named
Hank who's apparently a concierge doctor
for rich people I haven't seen that one
and then I'm watching a couple of my
favorite shows and on bones booths dad
is named Hank and then this week on
house there's a freakin porn star named
Hank give me my name back I'm okay I'm
going to regret this one but I am
annoyed that you can't talk about
evolution without sparking a gigantic
and uninteresting debate in the comments
for reference see the gigantic and
uninteresting debate going on below me
now I am annoyed by the fact that my
brother who shares this videoblog with
me if you're confused about who John is
has 1 million Twitter followers and I
have 10,000
what the Frick people I'm not saying
that John isn't cooler than me or that
I'm not really happy that I have 10,000
Twitter followers which seems really
ridiculous to me but there's a little
man inside of me who still got that
competitive urge with John he's my big
brother you know ain't never gonna go
away
on the same page I am annoyed that there
were 2,000 comments left about how to
punish me when there were like two
comments left about how to punish John
John is getting punished to people
please leave comments telling me out to
punish my brother down there amongst the
gigantic and uninteresting debate about
evolution I am annoyed that there is
still a part of me that can be annoyed
even when I have 50 million things to be
thankful for John have a very happy
Thanksgiving sorry we couldn't spend it
together I always miss you the most of
holidays and congratulations on let it
snow your book with Maureen Johnson and
Lauren Myracle
for becoming a New York Times best
seller if you don't have it this is the
time my friends it is wintertime
let it snow is a wonderful wintertime
romp I don't even know what the word rob
means but it's a wrap
john dftba
you